Cancer cannot grow in an alkaline body. If that statement is true, is there a list of
foods to eat that supports an alkaline body and list of foods that to avoid that
doesn't support that? Well, if anybody's been listening to me for any length of
time, they know that I don't believe that statement whatsoever. And that is just
there's so much untruth to that statement from a physiological perspective. And I
won't and I talk about this in my book. I talk about this in different long
posts and in tons of different Zoom calls, but I'll just briefly explain the
physiology. Your physiology is such that you do maintain a pH, intracellular
and extracellular. It means inside cells and outside cells, you'll maintain a pH. And then in your
blood, you even you maintain a very strict pH in your blood. Otherwise, you'll die. So how
you maintain that pH is through your body's buffering systems. Your body has these buffering systems.
Now, there may be an area in your body that's more acidic at different times in an area that's
more alkaline at different times. But let's make it very clear. You're in general, you're
going to stay maintained a pH that's fairly neutral. Just because something, you know, you've
heard time and time again that, you know, cancer grows in an acidic environment, you need to
alkalize, alkalize, alkalize, there is there's literally no truth to that statement whatsoever.
Any cell that's in rapid replication will give off a lot of waste. So when there's a lot of waste,
waste is going to be acidic. It'll be carried back through your limb system and out of your body.
It'll be carried into the blood through your limb system and it will be buffered. So the the
acidity of that waste will be buffered in your blood. Now, part of the buffering system that will
take something that's acidic and make it alkaline is that this is where you pull nutrients, pull
minerals from your other tissues and from your bones to help buffer it. You also have a buffering
system in your liver and in your stomach. Actually, the creation of HCl by your stomach cells actually
produces a side creation of sodium bicarbonate, which is used in your bloodstream as a buffering
system for the blood. So the production of HCl in your cyst in your stomach actually helps buffer
through alkalizing the rest of your body, you could say. That's the thing I didn't have to talk
about a lot with the total misnomer of people drinking alkaline water or taking sodium bicarbonate,
mix it in their water, make it a very alkaline water, and drinking that. You're really alkalizing the
HCl in your stomach, thereby actually acidifying your body. So you have to understand physiology here.
So I would agree that at the cancer site, if you have a solid cancer, not the blood cancer,
it's not multiple by loa.mochemia, but even not lymphoma in the blood. But if you have a lymphoma
hard solid tuber, lymphoma, at that solid tuber, whether it's a breast cancer or brain cancer,
it is going to be, if you could slice it open, it's take a pH strip in there, it is going to be more
acidic. Simply because any rapid replication of cells are going to create an acidic area, an acidic
slime layer of the cell. So if we could inject the tumor of a sodium bicarbonate,
like Dr. Simon Cheedy did in Italy, that might be beneficial. Hence, why this person is doing,
that asked that question. Here is doing sodium bicarbonate in of us because they have
a cancer in the rectal area that the sodium bicarbonate could knit at. So they're trying to
alkalize the tumor, you're not killing the tumor by alkalizing it, but you're right,
you tell the acidic layer that you're, so your immune system can better get at it to kill it.
So long story short, when you're eating good foods, you are helping your body stay
buffered when you're getting good minerals, you're helping your body in its buffering system.
The idea that is out there in the alternative community that you eat meat, you're acidifying your
system, and you're damaging your system, it's just complete physiological nonsense. I'm sorry, but
there's, there's doctors who write books about this stuff. It just, this is kind of bothers me,
and I get a little hot head in about this stuff because it makes alternative doctors look foolish
to anybody who's actually needs the science and understands physiology. So you're not, your purpose
is not to alkalize your body, your purpose is to get your body healthier. If you could inject the
tumor with sodium bicarbonate around the tumor, maybe there'd be benefits to that, we still don't know
about that. You can't legally do that and there could be other dangers of doing that. So I wouldn't
recommend doing that, but read some more of my stuff about that to really understand the physiology.
So I think that will help you. I think there's a lot of misinformation out there and that misinformation
bothers me because it makes all alternative doctors seem foolish and I think that's not good.